you will
[Music]
be popular you're going to
be conclave has been awarded best
screenplay at the Golden Globe Awards
oh thank you a gripping story where
Hollywood drama meets The Mystery of the
Vatican one standout Choice director
Edward Burger's bold use of red and
purple throughout the film but what's
the significance of these colors and why
the key in moving the story forward
let's unpack the deeper symbolism behind
conclave conclave won a Golden Globe for
best screenplay this last Sunday have
you guys seen the movie no okay so
basically the movie is about the pope
dies in the Vatican and they're having
to vote in a new pope there's a lot of
drama behind the scenes trying to figure
out who that is going to be now I found
it interesting uh that they use a
certain color scheme because obviously
they want to be um as realistic to the
Vatican and how they operate as possible
while adding in some fiction of course
it's like historical fiction yes it's
historical fiction and uh two colors
stand out and we're going to look at
them right now
[Music]
Scotty purple and Scarlet purple and
Scarlet okay so first of I've put two
questions for you one you worked in
Hollywood couple years ago um what
what's what's the deal with color
psychology movies well colors can can
give you a sense of an emotion that
they're trying to portray so um you know
if there's a lot of like stark contrast
and red is red is a very like you know
it's just a very like color that catches
your eye um purple obviously being like
a like a royalty so um I I think it's
the same reason why they have purple and
Scarlet in in in Catholicism right it's
it's they're meaning sacrifice they're
meaning like royalty mhm here you have
it purple and Scarlet it's this is why
they were putting it in the movie
because it's part of the Vatican and uh
yeah they were trying to be you know
realistic obviously but you have seen
scarlet and purple in a lot of other
movies as well right can you mention a
few I think this kind of caught my
attention when I started looking into
some of the cartoons we just did a thing
on Ice Age and um they had a dragon that
was part of the story that was a sort of
a purple and scarlet color um but I
started like kind of diving back into a
lot of the Disney Princesses and noticed
I mean even Frozen purple and Scarlet
she's in purple and Scarlet um and um in
um what's the new one with the Stars
make a wish something or other oh I
don't remember the name of that it's
just wish wish yeah yeah she she's in
purple and Scarlet um way back in um
Aladdin purple and Scarlet so I think
that's a theme that's that's utilized
and so it's interesting imagery
considering that the woman means a
church we'll look at that in just a
second but I also want to mention uh
Transformers oh yeah Transformers that's
why we did catch it in
[Music]
Transformers you defend my
family or die
aots we're going to prove who we are did
you notice how Optimus is painted purple
and Scarlet while he's riding on a
dragon so let's look at some Bible
prophecy because this is fascinating now
when I mention these texts right if you
don't understand Revelation 17 this is a
direct reference to to the Antichrist
this is the Antichrist that we are
describing right here H and we have a
video on that what the Antichrist is and
what the mark of the beast is make sure
you check it out because you will
understand that a lot this a lot better
when you watch that video but we're
going to look at the color science of
purple and red that we see in the Bible
in Revelation 17 which refers to a
church interestingly like you're
bringing it up Scotty and at the end
stay tuned because at the end of these
couple of verses we're going to show you
the purple and Scarlet in the Bible and
uh how it relates to the end times but
but Revelation 17:1 says come I will
show you the Judgment of the great
Harlot who sits on many Waters Keith
according to Ephesians 5:25 what is a uh
um Harlot or a woman in the Bible yeah
generally in the Bible when it comes to
prophecy a a woman represents a church
and it can be a pure church or it can be
an impure church and that's determined
by context so yeah yeah there is
actually also an IM pure Church being
shown in the Revelation yeah we find
references to Israel in the Old
Testament being described as a lovely
and delicate woman and things of that
nature Harlot that sits on many Waters
the Bible describes Waters as people's
tongues and Nations y we got that right
here so the same verse also talks about
that the Harlot sits in many Waters but
like he said Revelation 17:15 says then
he said to me the waters which you saw
where the Harlot sits are peoples
multitudes Nations and tongues it's
really cool the just explains itself
right it's its own interpreter yeah you
don't have to guess what it's trying to
say NOP and on her forehead a name was
written mystery Babylon the great the
mother of harlots and of the
Abominations of the earth Revelation
175 Revelation talks often about the
Babylonian system and the Babylonian
system is really um sort of in um
competition with God's system the
Babylonian system is a system of
confusion it's a system of blending
together because back in Babylon when
they would overtake a nation they would
grab those people no matter what they
believed and and they would want to
incorporate those people into their
society so instead of just saying like
you're now part of Babylon um you you
can't do anything that you've done
before they would just kind of soak up
what they were worshiping what they were
doing and just kind of integrate them
because the best people that want to
serve your country are the best people
that want to be there and so the Bible
talks about in the um in in in
Revelation the system of Babylon is
really a spiritual confusion it's a it's
a blending of all these different Church
ideas together and ironically that is
actually what we see in Catholicism we
see a blending of a lot of different
spiritual ideas that's why the pope has
the um fish Deon hat there's there's a
lot of different religious ideas that
are Blended together in that system in
Revelation 17 it's describing it very
well for a reason because when you get
to Revelation 18 then that system the
Bible shows come crashing down this is
where you have the merchants of the
Earth the crying like oh no Babylon is
Fallen well we've identified what
Babylon is in Revelation 17 and other
parts of the Bible but in Revelation 18
it's it's it's Fallen it's laid bare and
it's interesting because if you look at
this from a big you know 30,000 ft
perspective um the merchants they're not
sad that Babylon is has fallen for any
reason but themselves in other words I
can't really benefit from this anymore
it's not about what's happening to the
people or what's happening to Babylon or
anything else and they really embody
what Babylon is teaching which is really
selfishness so Revelation 18 from a big
Cosmic perspective is there's a kingdom
of selfishness and then you see a
demonstration of what God's people is
like especially in the early verses of
Revelation 18 where they are spreading a
message of love love to the people of
the world as history WS wraps up in that
love is you know communicates the gospel
in all its fullness yeah and when you
look at Daniel 2 you see that
Nebuchadnezzar had the dream M of a
statue which was literally the a dream
of the Nations the world kingdoms the
most prominent kingdoms that were going
to follow Babylon so the head of gold of
the statue was Babylon then there was
the the chest of silver and the arms of
silver which was Meo Persia then you had
the thighs of bronze which was Grease
and you had the legs of of iron and a
feet of iron and Clay there's lots of
different Scholars from different
denominations that understand this but
you know this this this ideology of
Babylon just crept down through the
statue through the Nations over time and
once you got to Rome which out of which
came the Roman Catholic Church was still
mixed in there it was literally it's
paganism mixed with with religion with
Christianity and we've got a show coming
up um about the origins of 666 and how
you know 666 actually is a symbol that
references to the Sun and Sun worship
which is very prominent in the Roman
Catholic Church as well and if you look
at some of the symbols of the
Babylonians a lot of the the um regalia
of the Catholic Church include that as
well the exact same symbol so there is
absolutely a mes M up still in Babylon
and we do want to say for those at home
who are Catholic I was you know uh
attending a Catholic church when I was
younger I was baptized into the Catholic
church I had to do my classes I had been
given a rosary to pray with so we are
not coming at you we we love Catholics
we are just sharing this out of love and
we have a lot of respect for anybody who
um is a Catholic and I think it's really
interesting though that is written on
her forehead because that's her thinking
her reasoning her mindset is a
Babylonian selfish mindset I like how
you brought that up yeah the kingdom of
selfish versus a kingdom of love I think
it's it's also more than that you know
God calls um his people in the last days
to be a kingdom of uh a nation of Kings
and Priests right Kings and Priests
Kings royalty priest um you know having
to do with re religious rights and
services and
Ministry but when you look at the Old
Testament system and you look at the way
God set it up not the way man set it up
but the way God set it up the priest had
something written essentially in his
forehead Holiness to the Lord it was
Holiness to the Lord it wasn't you know
mystery Babylon the great mother of
Harlot it was something entire entirely
different this is in God's way of saying
this is what you should be thinking and
then in Revelation 17 you have God
saying this is what you are yeah and on
top of that of course the final battle
on on in Earth's history is going to be
with the mark of the beast the mark of
the beast is in the forehead or in the
hand which we have videos on that too
yes the forehead the frontal low right
right you you think you make decisions
with that part of your brain you worship
god with that part of your brain the
hand is act um you know or you get the
steal of God right here it's it's all
connected so yes check that video out as
well Link in the description all right
next verse and the woman whom you saw is
that great city which Reigns over the
Kings of the earth Revelation
1718 and Revelation 171 and2 with whom
the kings of the earth committed
fornication and the inhabitants of the
earth were made drunk with the wine of
her fornication do we see this yes we do
oh it's no secret that um the the
Catholic system the papal system has
been very influential in world events
and world
history um you know economic
politically um just about every area of
society so when the Bible's you know
giving these signs and saying you know
it's committed fornication with the
merchants of the Earth the inhabitants
of the earth were made drunk in other
words this has had great influence we'll
say that's probably a good word great
influence over the whole earth and not
just any church can say that yeah you
can't just go to you know um whatever
XYZ Church down the street that exists
and said this this has had great
influence but this one yeah until 1798
when that power was seemingly to be
taken off of the world stage the wound
was the wound was given inflicted right
but isn't it interesting in our day and
age that you start to see this coming
out I mean I remember as a kid not
hearing too much about this uh from time
to time maybe but but it seems like in
my adult life life I've seen
increasingly more and more presence and
power especially with the world leaders
and everybody else giving attention back
to this organization yes so let's take a
look at a couple clips that shows you
how active the pope is uh in in meddling
with political Affairs and world
[Music]
leaders for
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
[Applause]
okay gets around he get he gets around
he travels yeah yeah he's definitely in
some some positions of power at this
point mhm so those are not the only
points of interest here let's look at
Revelation 179 here is the mind which
has wisdom the seven heads are seven
mountains on which the woman sits do you
guys know that the Rome was established
on Seven Hills mhm and we can see them
right here in this picture it's a
capitoline the Corino the viminol the
esquiline the Cen the Palatine atine um
so hey it's I I can't find any other
church or religious institution that is
according to the Bible you know woman is
a church that has all of these
identifying marks and fulfills all of
them Revelation 17:6 I saw the woman
drunk with the blood of the Saints and
with the blood of the martyrs of Jesus
and when I saw her I marveled with great
amazements I mean I think we've lost
count of how many millions millions
millions of Christians died during the
time of the Reformation because they
were persecuted for their faith because
they were standing up to the system like
like yeah we want the Bible you know
loving a half the Bible in our own
language we cannot read it and when they
start understanding the Bible as it was
being translated they realized wait a
minute you're the Antichrist system and
we don't want to follow worship you we
want to have our own faith we want to
follow the Bible and the Bible alone and
then they were Slaughter for it Millions
were Slaughter for it and in fact
interesting note we have a video on this
too um the pil pilgrims who fled this
persecution who came to the United
States who were the forefathers of many
people on in this country were actually
wrote had little notes in their Geneva
Bible that said we believe that the
Antichrist is the papacy interesting
yeah Revelation 174 now now we get back
to the colors what do these colors mean
that they show in this movie which they
were pretty spot on with the woman was
arrayed in purple and Scarlet and
adorned with gold and precious stones
and Pearls having in her hand a golden
cup full of Abominations and a
filthiness of fornication we looked at
this earlier which church uses red and
purple yeah yeah I mean I don't know if
there's any other ones that really do
but yeah for sure this is a prominent
color scheme yeah and Keith you said
that in the sanctuary in the Bible they
also use these colors but they're the
Catholic church is missing a color they
did they used the purple they used the
Scarlet but in the Old Testament they
also used blue what's very fascinating
is you find that color largely
missing uh at least in a prominent way
in Catholicism and so the question is
you know
why why is the blue left now I'm not
saying you know they they did this on
purpose maybe they did maybe they didn't
maybe it's just you know what happened
through history and God is uh revealing
like hey look what's missing and
interestingly enough but if you look
at a interesting story in Exodus or not
Exodus numbers 15 in numbers 15 you can
break this up into the sections in the
latter part one of those sections which
starts in verse 22 is the laws
concerning unintentional sin so after
Moses had given you know um a lot of
well given the Ten Commandments then
they started to spell things out more
specific
in certain areas so you have the laws
concerning uncal or unintentional sin
after that you have another section
called laws concerning presumptuous sin
so this is like your premeditated murder
type stuff you know it's like um they
knew
better right after that those two
categories is a story and it's a story
that I will often Point people to uh to
prove a point and the story is about
this man who is found out in the
wilderness on the Sabbath day and he's
Gathering sticks for
firewood and the children of Israel are
not sure what to do with him they bring
him to Moses and they're like hey what
do we we found this guy doing this what
do we do Moses is going of like don't
know let me go ask God and so they take
him to the Lord and this is what God
tells Moses the man must surely be put
to death all the congregation shall
Stone him with stones outside the camp
so as the Lord commanded Moses all the
congregation brought him outside the
camp and stoned him with stones and he
died and this is one of those stories in
the Old Testament that people look at
and they're like wow that is really
harsh like at least it seems harsh like
what's going on it's important to see
you this in context because you have the
law of unintentional sin after that you
have the law of presumptuous sin and
right after that follows this
story what's going on there was some
presumptuous sin the Sabbath had been
communicated he knew fourth Commandment
right he knew but he went out and did
his own thing anyway so when you look at
what's going on the guy what's implied
is he's in Rebellion he knows and he's
he's basically saying don't care what
God says I'm going to do my own thing
anyway mhm and that rebellious attitude
of course God being the ultimate judge
God knew like this isn't
changing so he
became uh he received the penalty right
then and there for for for death because
God is looking into his heart and saying
it's not going to change and he's going
to seow seeds of rebellion in other
people right after this after this
incident God tells the children of
Israel to do something to remember the
incident it's not the first time he's
done many many things in the Bible where
he tells them do this so you'll remember
right even the Sabbath command starts
with the words remember right yep if you
look in the box right the the the um Arc
of the Covenant there's three things in
there got for the purpose of remembering
than the Mana right the Ten Commandments
and Aaron Aaron's Rod that budded
Aaron's Rod that budded happens right
after this story because you have the
rebellion of Kora and all all that so
anyway getting back to the story in
numbers 15 what does God tell them to do
he tells them you know what make some
tassels on the corners of their garments
throughout their generations and to put
a blue thread in the tassels of the
corners and you shall have the tassel
that you may look upon it and remember
all the Commandments of the Lord and do
them that you may not follow the
harlotry to which your own heart and
your own eyes are inclined and that you
may remember and do all my Commandments
and be holy for your God and then he
reminds him you know I'm the god that
brought you out of the land of Egypt
when you read the story carefully you're
getting he broke one of The Commandments
and God said well to help you remember
put this blue thread in the him of your
garment so the color blue is telling us
something right God is using his own
color science and saying blue represents
my law my Commandments we can see this
in other places in scripture you look at
uh Exodus 2 410 it says and they saw
there the god of Israel and there was
under his feet as it were a paved work
of sapphire stone and it was like the
very heavens and its Clarity sapphire
stone at God's
feet what is this Moses Aaron the Elders
of Israel they're all on the Mountaintop
meeting with God having lunch and they
see God sitting on his throne and
there's this blue sapphire stone there
there's another person in the Bible who
sees this is
Ezekiel and um he says and above the
firmament over their heads was the
likeness of a
throne in appearance like a sapphire
stone and on the likeness of the throne
was the likeness in appearance of a man
high above it so he's looking up and
seeing the vision of God a references
this also in Ezekiel 10 where he sees
this sappire Stone mhm so um Lucifer if
you do a interest interesting study of
the Bible Lucifer has a topdown
perspective of this because he stands in
the presence of God as a covering cherub
right like this so his eyes often times
would have been looking
down when God references Lucifer in
Ezekiel 28 it says he had this very
distinct privilege and that was to walk
up and down in the midst of the stones
of fire
okay you put all that together what is
this Stone right Moses is referencing it
God gave him tablets of stone which if I
remember right I think there was a
reference to those being Sapphire being
Sapphire I've studied that too and you
have Ezekiel looking up seeing Sapphire
and you have Lucifer looking down and
seeing stones of fire put it all
together this is referencing the law in
some shape or form right wow once again
pointing us to
blue and one of the contentions in
protestantism versus Catholicism is the
law of
God what is more important is it the
Bible and God's law or is it what the
church or the magisterium says and they
have a tendency to put it on equal
footing or even sometimes Elevate their
tradition or the magisterium above God's
law so they even say in their own
writings that changing the Sabbath Ching
God's law is a mark of their own
authority
MH have you any other way of proving
that the church has power to Institute
festivals of precept answer had she not
such power she could not have done that
in which all modern religionists agree
with her she could not have substituted
the observance of Sunday the first day
of the week for the observance of
Saturday the 7th Day a change for which
there is no scriptural Authority
Protestants accept Sunday rather than
Saturday as the day for public worship
after the Catholic Church made the
change but the Protestant mind does not
seem to realize that in observing Sunday
they are accepting the authority of the
spokesman for the church the pope
question which is the Sabbath day answer
Saturday is the Sabbath day question why
do we observe Sunday instead of Saturday
answer
we observe Sunday instead of Saturday
because the Catholic Church transferred
the semity from Saturday to Sunday the
church is above the Bible and this
transference of Sabbath observance from
Saturday to Sunday is proof positive of
that fact so that color blue
interestingly enough throughout history
is missing in their own color
iconography y but it points to the
reason of why it's missing y yeah very
good point thank you Keith so going back
to this verse It also says that it was
adorned with gold and precious stones
and Pearls having a golden cup in her
hand did you guys know that the Catholic
church is the richest religious
institution in the world probably has
been for centuries I think collectively
yes if you look at one organization I
think it's the Mormons as far as net
worth but after that is a whole bunch of
individual Catholic churches like the
Catholic Church of Germany the Catholic
Church of this the cath but collectively
yes very rich so we talked about the
Reformation during the time of the
Reformation there are a lot of artists
that actually came out and made
paintings yeah side by side of Jesus on
the mule and the pope and how he was
dressed up to make to protest to make a
statement um so this is actually a
painting that's from Glasgow life
museums and artuk has a description
about it it says Christ and the pope
face each other Christ is mounted on a
donkey wearing his crown of thorns and
humble habit making a blessing gesture
the frowning richly dressed Pope by
contrast is crowned with gold and rides
a proud white charger the poem in
Germanic dialect below makes further
explicit comparisons between the humble
appearance and actions of Christ and
those of the pompous Pope referring
throughout to Christ as the Lord and the
pope as the servant the final summings
up sentence translated reads the servant
acts in opposition to the Lord
that's interesting they they they show
Jesus being a servant and the pope being
a Lord but the pope is actually supposed
to be like Christ dating from the 16th
century this is a propaganda painting of
the Reformation period with a clear
anti-papal message this is one of the
several known versions of the work which
uses an image and message which
originated as a woodcut print this
painting is particularly important as it
sums up in a visual and easily
accessible way the Contemporary
arguments for reform of the church and
provides ideal material for various
forms of interpretation so you know this
is why a lot of people like Pope Francis
nowadays because he kind of stepped away
from that kind of pump you know and like
start started driving his Pope mobile
which is the smaller car and all those
kind of things but you got to bear in
mind that the Pope the Pope Francis is
actually the first pope from the Jesuit
order and if you watch any of our videos
we have got a few of them the Jesuit
order is in fact order that was put in
during the time of the
Reformation as a secret society that was
supposed to counter the work of the
Reformation they were supposed to
actually um dress up and act like
Christians as Protestants and look
humble and do the same thing so but then
they could plant seeds to bring them
back to the Catholic church and back to
the mother church and they're highly
active today as well um I encourage you
guys at home go check it out we got a
couple videos on it that shows you and
this explains why Pope Francis is
dressed like this and acts like this
because he's a Jesuit and he is actually
part of a secret society the Vatican
puts in I know this might sound
absolutely crazy but we've got facts
upon facts upon facts that this is the
case and that they're still doing the
work of countering the Reformation so
any last thoughts purple Scarlet
prophecy we have purple and Scarlet on
our set we do and and I don't think we
put a blue except for Den's phone yeah
yeah and you guys have blue eyes so you
know we're countering this we're good
we're good I think I'm toast but uh no
you know I think I think it's really
interesting once again to reaffirm that
the Bible is is is such an amazing book
I mean really it's it's it's
interpreting what's going on throughout
history what's been what's in the what's
in the future the past and I think all
these books are very important espe
especially the books of Daniel and
Revelation for today's yeah read it
Revelation 1:1 says the revelation of
Jesus Christ it matters as much as
reading the gospels yep amen cool thank
you guys so much for watching please
make sure you hit like And subscribe it
gets the video up in algorithm so more
people can see this and again you want
to learn more about Bible prophecy make
sure you check out our online free bible
school it's LL S.T v/b School Link in
the description also make sure you check
out our videos on the Jesuit and uh on
what the Antichrist or who the
Antichrist power is uh 666 what is that
and what is the mark of the beast I'm
telling you this is the time to look
into this to study it for yourself and
again the Bible explains itself
shockingly the mark of the beast is not
a barcode or a chip or or even um a
vaccine it's it's the Bible explains
exactly what it is and also if you want
to support our ministry you can do so by
going to
ls. give or
patreon.com Light Studios we'll show you
we'll actually have a lot of cool behind
the-scenes stuff on there as well for
all of our supporters or you can go to
lightwear do shop and get some of our
cool Christian merch that we designed
he's wearing one right now and we
actually have a really cool new prophecy
we do merch line yes coming up soon
still needs to be on the website but
it'sing com coming soon at lightwear do
shop it's actually the four kingdoms we
mentioned from Daniel 2 Bible verse on
the back it's it's really awesome so
make sure to check that out and you can
be a walking billboard for Jesus thank
you guys for watching we'll see you next
[Music]
time hey subscribe to little Studios
if you want to learn Spanish a great way
will be watching our videos for
[Music]
practice I'm sorry do we know each other
it seems like maybe we've met before I
don't know this is uh it's awkward
though just as much for me as it is for
you I really wish I had a conversation
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]